[Applause]
in this connection I want to stress once
more
the special military operation in the
Ukraine and the donbass which started in
February all the objectives will be
definitely
carried out to guarantee the security of
people in the danetsk and Logan's
People's Republic the Russian Crimean
all our country we must understand that
our soldiers and officers have prevented
a real threat which was hanging over our
motherland with their courage
resoluteness and heroism they private
prevented a large-scale conflict which
would uh
spread on our territory according to
other people's scenario the forces which
have historically contained Russia
historically contained
in olden times two you know this very
well such an independent why did they do
that because such an independent a huge
country they don't need such a country
they think that it's just by existed it
presents a threat to them even though
it's not true
presents a threat to the whole world
themselves we remember that the plans of
the fascists against the Soviet Union to
uh
to make people who can work force that
those people work to be slaves and those
who couldn't work should go to Siberia
and died there that was a historical
document we remember this document we
also remember how Western States at the
beginning of the 1990s and 2000s
encouraged International terrorists and
bandits and North caucuses how they
speculated on the problems of our past
and of course
those were problems in the injustices in
relation to whole Nations whole peoples
in the Caucasus for example but they
didn't do that to improve us not at all
they did that so that they could move
the problems of the past in into our
today's life to encourage a separate
systems moods in our country and finally
to split it and to destroy it that's why
they did that and finally to push us
into a corner into a bear's Corner in
the past many tried to do this against
Russia
but they haven't reached the objective
but they didn't reconcile with this with
this failure they didn't reconcile but
the fact that despite their Onslaught we
held out that's why later they began to
prepare an economic war against Russia
step by step step they used any excuses
and sometimes even without any excuses
they implemented new sanctions
restrictions and even today's plans to
strangle us economically have failed in
this connection our country's enemies
creation of new geopolitical weapons
they are not really new but they created
a new impulse they reckoned
phobia would do this they uh for years
they turned Ukraine our neighboring
Ukrainian to anti-russia Let's remind
you that Russia was also always
sympathetic and acted as a friend and as
a comrade as a a brother
viewed the creation of the independent
Ukrainian States at the time we expected
that this would be a friendly country
that we would develop together and
strengthen each other and create the
best conditions for our competition and
development
and of course we didn't expect that they
would create until Russia on that
territory we cannot allow this and of
course in the end they caused and pushed
Ukraine to have a direct confrontation
in our country like the military at sex
on the dunbas and Crimea were in the
doctrines
and the Ukrainian people were and as a
consumables and many Ukrainian people
are now realizing this such as
regime its desire to have nuclear
weapons and the creation of a biological
labs and the supply of latest weapons of
the Ukraine all that confirms that our
reaction to all that was a timely and
correct esteemed colleagues I want to
stress once more our soldiers and
officers and the militia of danbas are
carrying out their missions heroically
all the objectives that have been said
will be carried out